on va te faire une petite interview afin
d'en but c'est ce que c'est l'interview
à peine down voilà whiting ce qui te
plaît le plus dans la vie en général
en général si c'est la générosité france
les gens quand ils rencontrent la rue
qui sont qui vous vous êtes à vivre 20
ce qui vous aident à vivre ce site c'est
le plus chiant il supporte le bon choix
pour moi je supporte pas il ya plein de
choses que je ne supportais pas que le
racisme et les guerres la méchanceté
si ce qui est c'est ce qui est triste
pour l'instant la pauvreté le chômage
donc j'ai visité du papier à mélanger
décidé l'année dernière c'est cette
gaffe et le plus grand score dit ma vie
que je veux quand tu pleures ce mardi
alors le site peta préféré faire le lit
pas la leçon parce que je suis là c'est
trop cher mais c'est le candidat préféré
bon allez je dirais une rue pas si oui
je peux pas dire là je dirais pire le
fou et le plus gonflé le film vraiment
simon king of web étudient ou axa fenua
tu dis je suis moralement aussi le jour
où j'ai rencontré ce metteur en scène
j'ai pu le casting jenson était aussi
bien annoncé prévoit non pas une flamme
ardente rejoue la a6 le pire c'est que
il ya là plusieurs d'entre eux
on avait tous des trucs pourris y est
sûrement pour mais non des moindres
on attendait qu'est-ce que j'ai vraiment
fait un film qui nous gonflent est
complètement bon mais là c'est très
méchant joue également
je vais dire mais dénué s'agit de jean
luc godard si vous voulez vraiment je
n'aime pas ces retards dus ces deux joué
dans à bout de souffle un petit tir oui
parce que je l'aï rencontré il m'a dit
matt moselle il faut déshabillez moi
j'ai dit monsieur je ne mettais à gaza
et sont repartis trois mois plus tard
j'ai reçu un télégramme il m'a dit
mademoiselle cette fois ci c'est
peut-être pour le rôle principal
alors maintenant on va passer aux choses
intimes ne pas y couper la paille sinon
on al badri chaleur dont il va mettre de
côté denis de libérer parce que je veux
dire bon ça sera un peu calé quel est le
résumé non
l'homme qui est impressionné par deux
niveaux alors je te juge de l'analyse
mais je compte sur toi pour être honnête
on m'a dit oui il ya des gens qui se
marient et ceux qui ne se marient pas
moi je me suis presque tu vois mariés
avaient déjà voyagé j'ai été mariée
c'est vrai quelques fois
mais j'ai pas tellement connu des hommes
il n'y a pas tellement par exemple était
pas marie avec lui non mais c'est
évidemment j'ai eu quelques âmes ans
quand même nom mais ça canton de vaud on
comprend mais je veux dire que tu as
quand même eu une aventure avec eux avec
jacques perrin s'est amusé c'est vrai ça
va lui avancer les gros seins avait s'il
était là on voit la même chose la
rassure toi là la fep a depuis repris
ici
alors jacques perrin maurice ronet
pierre fabre daniel duval j'ai pas dis
moi ton préféré jean luc godard on le
sait dix mois maritime de libérer je
vends sentir la bombe atomique est ce
que tu veux moi je suis très vite j'ai
pas que tu demandes à plein régime à
venir il ya marie merveilleux et on est
très complices et tout va bien on va
s'en plaindre
on va revenir à goller qu'est-ce que tu
préférais mais il avait derrière ses
lunettes noires ses tripes
qu'est ce qu'une émission s'appelle
comme ça sans ouais mais il avait un
très beau regard quand il avait passé
lorsqu'il avait je crois que c'était
facile ni complètement attiré comme
quelque chose qu'on n'explique pas
et puis bon ensuite ça a été une
histoire d'amour bouleversante
si l'état pour moi et puis il y avait
tout un débat n'est justement dans les
jouets les bassins c'est une très bonne
enchaînement ce que tu supportes est
proche et puis c'est bien un truc que je
supportais pas chez lui ces absences
voilà c'était tout le temps cette bêta
d'ie une fois dans un interview tu as
dit peut-être mon intelligence n'a pas
su se mettre à mon niveau c'est pareil
j'étais quand même une enfant rejeté
subir et il sait pas et c'est pourquoi
l'école l'importance actuelle d'ailleurs
ce qui fait que quand même j'avais au
départ pas beaucoup de cultures dont il
m'a tout appris jean-luc aussi fuir
c'était à la fois sa femme et ça
je prie aussi comme une enfant parce que
bon professeur oui mais maintenant ce
que tu aimes le plus sans toi à moi en
toi à moi même en toi là je n'ai même
fatiguée bien ce que tu aimes bien que
je pense que je suis plus tôt et j'ai
pas trop mauvaise ouais c'était marrant
toi
suite qu'est ce que tu as le plus sexy
en toi ton analyse ce qui est fait
craquer tous les mac quoi c'est quoi un
peu le savoir faire métier le ca ce
genre de choses et qu'est-ce que très
disponible et quand
est ce que tu as moins sexy le 10 sport
sera pas content parce que là ces femmes
pour moi au monde qui était vraiment
sexy c'est malin non